З настанням холодів в Україні - російські ракетні удари несуть нову загрозу:
руйнування будинків, квартир, відключення електроенергії.
В той час, коли людям потрібно тепло, щоб вижити.
Холодний жовтневий день у Харкові.
Ця вулиця стала епіцентром влучання російської ракети цього місяця.
Вікна майже кожного житлового будинку в кварталі - розбиті.
Через день після атаки тут розпочинають ремонт.
Така тактика має назву "швидке відновлення".
Це майже миттєве усунення незначних пошкоджень у будинках,
щоб люди могли лишатися у своїх квартирах.
Таким чином у безкоштовних притулках буде більше місця
для переміщених осіб, або для тих, хто потребує їх найбільше.
Найчастіше ми займаємося швидким відновленням.
Міняємо вікна, вивозимо сміття, ремонтуємо дахи.
Жінка, що проживала у цій квартирі, наразі живе у своєї родини.
Але вже за кілька тижнів після прибирання та відновлення
вона зможе повернутися сюди, кажуть волонтери.
Прибрати сміття і "закрити" вікна?
Ми точно можемо зробити це сьогодні.
Після того, як волонтери попрацювали над відновленням будинків
- одразу і не скажеш, що у цей квартал влучила російська ракета.
Але в північному передмісті Харкова – Салтівці – життя виглядає зовсім інакше.
У перші місяці війни район був обстріляний російською артилерією,
і мешканці, які залишилися тут, тепер переживають вже другу зиму без центрального опалення або ж навіть вікон.
Анна з мамою та подругою вже двадцять місяців
живуть у підвалі свого житлового будинку.
Вони переїхали у підвал, бо тут тепліше.
Тут немає вікон, і вони можуть грітися за допомогою обігрівачів
та старої дров'яної печі.
Не замерзнеш, але краще, ніж в квартирі.
Підтримка, перш за все, моральна.
Це для нас дуже важливо.
Всі інколи падаємо духом.
Спочатку це не так відчувалося,
але зараз все проходить, ми чекаємо закінчення війни, а її…
Анна планує повернутися з підвалу до квартири,
коли в будинку відновлять центральне опалення,
як це обіцяє уряд.
Але жодні роботи так і не почалися.
Жінка хвилюється, що за цей час будівля
може запліснявіти й почати псуватися,
і тоді вона вже ніколи не зможе повернутися.
Будинок Анни в кінці списку пріоритетів міста.
Згідно з державною політикою
- в першу чергу ремонтуються ті будівлі, які найменше постраждали.
Це дозволяє людям швидше повернутися з притулків до своїх осель.
Це дуже засмучує і гнівить мешканців Салтівки,
які не знають, де і як їм зустрічати другу зиму під обстрілами.
З мешканцями іншого будинку ми зустрічаємося поруч з їхніми розбомбленими будинками.
Вони майже втратили будь-яку надію бути почутими.
Багато з них живуть разом з іншими сім’ями тут неподалік.
Вони чекають поки їхні будинки відремонтують.
У державні гуртожитки переїжджати не хочуть, бо іноді це доволі далеко.
В нашому будинку вони пообіцяли, що ми стоїмо в 2024 році в плані на проєктну документацію.
Уявіть собі, тільки в 2024 році! Людям куди? Це зима…
За рік всі ці щілини будуть розходитися і все буде ще гірше.
Масштаб руйнувань вражає.
Будівлі тут зазнали численних прямих влучень російської артилерії та, за словами мешканців,
обстрілів з бойових літаків. Важко осягнути вартість відновлення,
особливо в той час, коли уряд зосереджує сили
для відсічі російських атак.
Мешканці готові зібрати гроші та відремонтувати свої квартири самостійно.
Втім, місто не може дозволити цього з міркувань безпеки
– пошкоджені споруди можуть обвалитися і забрати ще більше життів.
Мешканці третього під'їзду, власники своїх квартир вони взагалі не знають,
що їм робити. Вони не можуть подати заявку в "єВідновлення"
і їм не пропонують квартиру.
Люди  залишилися без нічого.
У сусідньому районі на півночі Харкова - вже завершується ремонт.
Будівлі оглянули на наявність структурних пошкоджень,
а робітники вже встановлюють нові вікна.
Деякі сім'ї нарешті повертаються додому.
В міському управлінні з будівництва, ремонту та реконструкції кажуть,
що розуміють, чому жителі Салтівки розчаровані.
Головна проблема в тому, що наразі законодавство,
яке регулює процедуру відновлення, воно створюється зараз.
Ми, звісно, проговорюємо з мешканцями Харкова процедури,
за якими буде проходити відновлення.
Різні будинки, різні категорії пошкоджень, тому різні підходи.
Забезпечення житлом тих, чиї будинки були пошкоджені
або зруйновані під час війни,
є лише одним із завдань української влади з настанням холодів.
Минулої зими війська РФ націлили всі удари на енергосистему України.
Що спричинило відключення електроенергії по всій країні.
Усі, з ким ми спілкувалися, іншого цієї зими не очікують.
Але є одне "але".
Україна багато чого дізналася про стратегію Росії
і цілий рік готувалася до цього холодного сезону.
По-перше, для українських систем ППО -
великі електропідстанції є пріоритетними для оборони.
Ці станції постачають електроенергію до півмільйона домогосподарств у великих містах,
таких як Київ.
Інженери також відновлюють менші підстанції,
пошкоджені під час російських атак.
Тепер їх розміщують у вибухостійкому бетоні.
Лише на Київщині у 2022 році
було зруйновано близько трьох тисяч місцевих підстанцій.
Нові ангари не можуть витримати пряме влучання ракети,
але вони створені для стримування осколків від вибуху поблизу.
Можливо, будуть якісь пошкодження. Якщо буде ураження.
Але вони не будуть такими суттєвими, ми можемо швидко відреагувати, відремонтувати
цей об’єкт і запустити його знову в роботу.
Попри вивчені уроки, енергетична інфраструктура України зустрічає
цю зиму в невигідному становищі.
Росія знищила величезну кількість дорогої техніки,
яка досі по частинах надходить в Україну.
Звичайно, життєстійкість енергосистем нижча,
ніж до того, як усе почалося.
Наша ситуація складна.
З одного боку, ми добре підготовлені, у нас є розуміння того,
що сталося, і ми готувалися до цієї зими.
З іншого боку, з точки зору обладнання, ми ослаблені.
На думку Олександра Харченко,
російські атаки на інфраструктуру не зможуть зломити українців.
Я вірю, що хоч і буде важко, але ми витримаємо.
Тим часом у центрі Харкова,
команда волонтерів попри сирени повітряної тривоги не зупиняє роботу.
Кожного разу, коли ви відновлюєте будівлю,
здається, що Росія скидає чергову бомбу на Харків.
Чи є у вас відчуття, що ваша робота нескінченна?
Наша робота нескінченна?
Ми не знаємо точно, але ми готові до всього.
Життя до 24 лютого і після - це різні життя.
Зараз ми робимо це знову і знову,
але в майбутньому війна закінчиться.
Ми не знаємо коли саме. Але ми готові до всього.